Justice Center to the world are getting
ready
oh and America
firstmeyer Germany
and Metcalf of America
[Applause]
Kansas wake up calf comes up
in 1936 Jesse Owens achieved Sports
immortality by winning four gold medals
at the Olympic Games which were being
held in Nazi Germany his victories came
after Hitler had criticized the U.S for
including black athletes on its Olympic
team while Owen's achievements are
Monumental one of his teammates laid the
foundation and now Generations later a
piece of his legacy continues to grow
John Blackstone has the story
the oak tree in a changing Los Angeles
neighborhood is all it remains of a
largely forgotten story of Victory race
and national pride
it begins at the 1936 Olympics in Berlin
that Adolf Hitler saw as a showpiece for
Nazi propaganda but Hitler's theory of
racial superiority was challenged on the
very first day of the games by a black
American Cornelius Johnson from
California won the high jump Cornelius
Johnson 22 year old from Los Angeles
soared to Victory setting an olympic
record and everybody up until that point
in the games had seen Hitler
congratulating the gold medalists from
Finland and from Germany Susan Anderson
is history curator for the California
African-American Museum and when
Cornelius Johnson's turn came to be
congratulated by Hitler Hitler refused
in response Olympic officials told
Hitler he had to congratulate all gold
medal winners or none Hitler chose none
so later in the games when the Great
American athlete Jesse Owens won four
gold medals just like every other winner
Hitler did not shake his hand so even
today people have this thought that
Hitler snubbed the famous athlete Jesse
Owens and that just isn't true actually
what happened was Cornelius Johnson
was the recipient of the Nazi snub
Hitler's snub was answered on the podium
when Johnson and the two other medal
winners both Americans raised their arms
in what could appear to be a Nazi salute
but with their palms turned up they were
doing what American school children did
every morning it was called the Bellamy
salute until the 1940s it was how
Americans saluted the flag reciting the
Pledge of Allegiance Americans would
recognize it and people would know that
they were making a statement about
democratic values in opposition to what
the Nazis stood for as Cornelius Johnson
saluted his other hand held a small tree
Hitler's government presented an oak
sapling to every gold medalist as a
symbol of German strength but the tree
came to symbolize something else planted
at Johnson's home in Los Angeles him
planting his tree was a way of saying I
beat you we won this tree has given me a
lot of insight into my own relationship
to life to the past to history Christian
Mayer a German artist living in Vienna
learned of the Olympic Oak when he was
in Los Angeles in 2014 it inspired some
of his art I was interested in trees
that have a very specific history that
comes with them something that we would
project onto them some sort of a
cultural history two years ago mayor
learned that Johnson's former home was
sold to a developer with plans for a
condominium the house and the tree would
be gone
from thousands of miles away mayor
organized a campaign to save the Olympic
Oak Tim Tebow an arborist at Huntington
Gardens in Los Angeles testified to the
tree's significance the gold medal
sitting in a case is one thing but a
tree that's been able to grow inside a
gold medal Was Won
um
is much more special and much more
powerful City officials agreed and
designated the home and the oak tree and
historical monument a few other Olympic
Oaks remain standing around the world
including one presented to Jesse Owens
in a park in Cleveland Cornelius Johnson
died of an illness at the age of 32 just
10 years after his Olympic Victory the
home his grandfather built in 1903 still
stands but it's in the Los Angeles
neighborhood that has changed greatly in
the 87 years the tree has been growing
there and now it grows in in what we
call Korea Town in Los Angeles a very
diverse multi-ethnical multi-language
area absolutely the opposite of what the
Nazis would have dreamed of as their
future and so I think it's a beautiful
symbol for how things can turn out much
better
Perfect Place perhaps for Cornelius
Johnson's Olympic Oak for CBS Saturday
morning John Blackstone Los Angeles
I love when he says a gold medal sitting
in a case right is one thing but a tree
that can be planted and grows and lives
on and develops and changes is another
says a lot doesn't it oh my gosh such a
brilliant story loved it